So good morning everyone.
It's 9:00 AM on the west coast, and I'm Alex
Bui, co-director of the BD2K Center's coordination
center.
So last time in the series, we completed our
discussions on data modeling and inference.
And today, we kind of shift gears to talk
about some other topics of interest in biomedical
big data.
So the first topic we'll be covering is one
of growing interest-- open science.
Questions around making science transparent
and reproducible and making it available has
important implications.
Not just within the academic and scientific
communities, but to the broader public.
And with us today is Dr. Brian Nosek, who
is a Professor of psychology at the University
of Virginia.
Doctor Nosek is co-founder and executive director
of the Center of Open Science, which advocates
and supports the practice of open science
on a global scale.
In 2015, he was named on Nature's 10 List,
and he's also on the Chronicle of Higher Education's
influence list.
Brian thank you so much for joining us this
morning.
I'm looking forward to hearing more about
open science and your perspectives on how
we as a community can enable it.
And with that, the floor is yours.
Thanks Alex.
I'm very happy to be speaking with this group
today.
The term open science is an unusual term,
because it is essentially redundant, right?
Scientific claims don't become credible based
on authority, or insistence that they're true,
or logical argument.
They become credible based on the availability
of the evidence that support the scientific
claim.
So that includes the outcome of the report
of what the person-- it's how they summarize,
how they did their research and arrived at
those claims.
It includes the materials and methodology
that was the basis for generating the evidence
or applying analytics to the data that are
generated.
And the data itself that are the content that
supports that claim.
So the fact that we have a discussion and
an unusual term about open science isn't suggesting
something about a different way of doing science,
but rather the fact that the values of openness
in science are not consistent, necessarily,
with the daily practice of how science is
operating today.
So really, the open science movement is about,
I think, values in addressing the gap between
daily practice and core principles of how
science is presumed to operate.
So one way to start is to just to review what
are those core principles of what makes science
science-- as a way of knowing, as a way of
learn about the world.
And Robert Merton talks about these in the
1940s and 50s, when he was trying to characterize
the norms of science or the values of science.
So one, he identified communality-- the open
sharing of information.
Claims become credible based on the sharing
of the evidence supporting those claims, versus
the counter-norm-- secrecy.
Nope, just got to trust me.
I'm a scientist, I know what I'm talking
about.
Just believe me.
The second-- universalism.
Research is evaluated based on its own merit,
right?
The evidence itself is the basis of deciding
whether the claims are credible or not.
Versus particularism-- evaluating research
based on the authority, the prestige, the
eminence of the person making the claim.
A third that Merton identified was disinterestedness.
Researchers are motivated by knowledge and
discovery, versus the counter-norm of self-interestedness--
just trying to get ahead of the person down
the hall.
Likewise, researchers are-- consider all new
evidence, even against prior work.
Organized skepticism versus the counternorm
of organized dogmatism.
I spend my career finding the initial results
and then fighting off all the attackers in
the field to defend my particular point of
view, my theory, my findings.
And while Merton didn't talk about it, a lot
of philosophers and sociologists of science
have talked about a norm of quality as compared
to the counter-norm of quantity.
Now those may be easily recognizable values
and norms of how science is perceived, but
a question is do actually researchers endorse
those norms?
Do they buy in to these as the values of science,
compared to those counter-norms that they
could buy into.
Anderson and her colleagues get a large-scale
survey of NIH ORDs.
Something like 3,300 people were in their
sample to see whether they endorsed the counter-norms
or the norms.
And they-- this graph here shows early career
which means people that were in a post-doctoral
award.
Mid-career were folks that were in their first
R01 awards, so average age around 40.
And what I'm showing you here is a cumulative
plot of the responses to that survey, where
the grey indicates people who endorse the
norms over the counter-norms on average.
Whereas black are those who endorse the counter-norms
over the norms on average.
So what you're seeing is 90% or so of the
participants in this survey said that they
endorse those norms of science over the counter-norms.
And the gray hatched lines are people that
said, well, I sort of endorse both of these
equally.
So there's broad endorsement for the norms
of science.
But then Anderson and her colleagues said
OK, that's fine.
Don't tell me what you endorse.
Tell me how you behave in your everyday research.
And it looks like this.
So mostly, still more than 60% of early and
mid-career researchers say that they behave
according to the norms of science.
But many are acknowledging that those counter-norms
of competition, of trying to get ahead, of
keeping information themselves, of dogmatic
thinking are driving their behavior to some
degree.
And still most people do not endorse-- say
that they don't behave according to counter-claims
over the norms.
Then they said, OK, OK.
Don't tell me what you do as an individual,
tell me about the people in your area of research.
How did they behave?
And the distribution of responses looks like
this.
So most people perceive that
their community-- the culture around them--
behaves more according to the counter-norms
rather than the norms of science.
And this is a challenging situation, because
the gap between what my values are-- those
first graphs saying I want to be open, I want
to be reproducible work, I want to be skeptical
about my own work.
Versus what I perceive is reinforced, is incentivized,
is the dominant behavior in my culture-- creates
a gap between how I think science should be
done and how I think it is being done and
what it takes to be successful in the field.
And that's a significant challenge.
And part of what is characterized as the reproducibility
crisis or whatever want to-- term you want
to use that's been in discussion in the last
few years-- is a lot of different kinds of
behaviors that may be good for advancing one's
own career-- making one's research more publishable--
but not necessarily good for the accuracy
or the reproducibility of the evidence.
And there are lots and lots of research and
discussions about the various areas of limitation
in the quality or rigor or reproducibility
of work.
But we can characterize some of the main ones
like this, right?
Low power.
Most of the investigations of the power of
research design suggests that we don't even
have enough power to detect the effects that
we are detecting, increasing both the likelihood
of Type I errors-- false positives-- and Type
II errors-- false negatives.
Researchers have remarkable flexibility in
the kinds of analyses that they do of the
same data and then can select among those
which are the analyses that are most favorable
to their interests, whether that interest
is publication or their particular point of
view, or whatever else.
I do many experiments in my lab and only a
subset of them get into papers.
So what is that process of selective reporting?
What ends up getting filtered out, and is
that a biasing influence over the reliability
of the work that's end up produced?
No results are considered less interesting,
even less interpretable, than positive results-leading
to them being more likely to be ignored, or
not published, or not even written up for
potential publication.
And the main driver of scientific success
is innovation.
Finding out new possibilities.
What things could be true.
Pushing new areas of interest that motivate
new theoretical domains or new possibilities.
And there are good incentives for replication.
For verifying findings that have been proposed.
For increasing the reliability of the estimates--
of effects that have been observed.
And so as a consequence, there's lots and
lots of innovation, but without the practices
of verification, of skepticism, of questioning,
of extending in incremental but cumulative
ways.
Now these are problems that have been well
discussed in the literature, and not just
in the last five or six years.
The references that I have below are just
a sample of the many methodologists' discussions
about these very issues that occurred in the
1950s, 60s, and 70s.
And all of the solutions that are being discussed
now for how we can increase reproducibly are
the same kinds of solutions that were identified
during that time period, suggesting that we
understand what the problem is and what the
solutions are.
We just haven't developed effective
mechanisms for addressing it.
And so at the Center for Open Science, we
exist as a nonprofit technology company that
has a mission to increase openness, integrity,
reproducibility of research.
And I want to just-- during this presentation
today-- give you an overview of some of the
activities that we have for trying to nudge
the practices of science to be more aligned
with those core values.
So the-- sort of the center of what we think
is the key challenge for increasing openness
and reproducibility in research is that the
incentives for my success as a practicing
researcher are focused on me getting it published,
not getting it right.
So the mechanisms of reward-- my likelihood
of getting my job, of getting tenure, of getting
advanced in my career depend-- at least the
easy way to characterize it-- is depend on
me publishing as frequently as possible in
most prestigious outlets that I can.
And not everything gets published.
So positive results are more likely to get
published than negative results.
Novel results are more likely to be published
than replications or redundant results.
And clean and tidy stories, where everything
fits together in a nice sequence are more
likely to get published than ones that have
lots of exceptions, lots of things that are
uncertain.
Positive, novel, clean results are a goldmine.
Those are the those are the golden eggs that
we might shoot for, because those are more
important, better results.
But of course, in few laboratories does that
happen very often, right?
We don't get positive, novel, clean and tidy
results very easily because we're studying
problems that we don't understand-- that's
why we're studying them.
And progress is healthy.
We get lots of exceptions.
Lots of things that don't make sense.
Many things that don't fit together.
Lots of false starts.
And that's just the process of doing research.
But all the incentives are pointing us to
turning that goop that's happening in the
lab into beautiful stories at the end that
show a clean and tidy sequence that may be
more beautiful than the evidence actually
supports.
And that's where a lot of the key challenges
are-- is that the published literature may
appear to be more reliable, more complete,
more credible than the evidence supporting
it actually is.
Because we don't actually see all of the evidence
that has been generated and is being used
to make the claims that appear in the literature.
So there are a lot of barriers to try and
to address and make all of that research process
more transparent so that it can be evaluated
by the research community, for the research
community to be able to do what the promise
of research is-- which is to be self-correcting.
We cannot self-correct if we don't know the
basis of evidence for the claims.
We can only self-correct based on what we
can see.
And of course, the papers that come out of
the research process from my lab-- David [? Donoho
?] at Stanford
characterized as advertising for the research,
not research itself.
It's my best description of what I think is
important about the work that we do that makes
it as publishable as possible and also it's
a clear and tidy and interesting to the reader.
But of course, the things behind it are where
the real research are-- the materials, the
methodology, the protocols, the data.
All of that work that is what generated research--
that's the real research itself.
So how can we make more of that accessible
so that the research community can be self-correcting?
Well there's a number of important barriers.
One of them are those perceived norms that
we just talked about on the initial slide,
where I see the culture being one of secrecy,
of people are advancing their careers, of
being dogmatic in their approach.
And I don't see myself wanting to do that,
but I have-- I'm confronted with a choice.
I can either stay true to the values that
I have, of wanting to do science as it's supposed
to be done.
But at the cost of career advancement, because
I see that there are other practices that
are accelerating people's careers.
Or I could give in and sacrifice some of those
values and be able to advance my career by
doing some of the behaviors that are more--
that are better for career advancement even
though they might not be better for science.
And that's a difficult situation for anyone
to be in.
A second barrier is that we have these amazing
frontal lobes that give us lots of flexibility
and reasoning.
Where when we're confronted by multiple ways
we could analyze the data-- some of them look
better for publication than others.
Multiple studies that we could use to make--
be the basis of our claims-- some of which
look better for publication or for our existing
theories than others, that we are likely to
employ our reasoning.
Not as reasoning to arrive at a conclusion,
but as rationalization to justify a conclusion
that we already have.
And that is a lion's share of how reasoning
actually works-- is that we have existing
beliefs and we look for information that helps
to support our existing beliefs, our existing
stakes.
So that we employ things like confirmation
bias, seeking information consistent with
our current points of view.
We employ hindsight bias.
Once we see results, we look at the results
that are best for us and say, oh of course.
That's how we would have done this study.
That's the right kind of result to pay attention
to.
That's what I would have expected to have
occurred.
And so all of those reasoning strategies many
unintentionally-- without even being aware
of that I'm employing them-- may be shaping
the literature coming out of my lab to look
better than it actually is.
A third barrier is that a lot of that happens
with very little accountability.
None of you know what happens in my lab.
All you get to see is the reports of the end.
And so I don't have the conditions, the situation,
of perspective-taking.
Of, as we are reasoning through, trying to
do our research, of thinking about how would
an observer evaluate the decisions that we're
making here?
The decision to drop that study?
To amplify that analysis?
To suppress that analysis?
Would they think that that is a reasonable
thing to do?
And as we know from a lot of research on accountability,
that perspective-taking, or knowing that someone
could observe what I'm doing fundamentally
changes how I think about those problems.
What decisions I make about what I'm going
to do and how I'm going to do it.
And then lastly, we're very busy.
We're all very busy.
And so the ideas of being more transparent,
of making your data more accessible, of opening
up our materials, our process of research--
all of those are perceived-- and in reality,
many times-- as an extra work.
As an appendage on the existing work flows.
And if-- in a competitive landscape like science--
in a place where we are over-committed already
with a variety of projects that we're trying
to pursue and understand and do-- we are not
likely to be easily amenable to adding on
new things that we have to do in order to
make that research more accessible.
Especially if we're not incentivized to do
it.
If there is no reward for me making my data,
my materials, my protocols more open, then
why would I spend that extra time doing it?
Even with the values of desiring that as a
good outcome.
So those are formidable barriers.
And there's a lot that needs to change in
the culture in order to try to address improvements
of openness and reproducibility as ordinary
practice.
So there are a few areas that the Center for
Open Science focuses on to try to maximize
the likelihood that we can move to a more
open and reproducible research culture.
First strategy is that we are primarily a
technology company.
We have a staff of 55 and about 2/3 of that--
full-time staff 55.
There's interns as well.
But about 2/3 of that staff is building tools
like the open science framework to enable
researchers to be more open with their research.
We also provide training, as many others do,
for how to be more open and reproducible in
research practices.
And then the third is providing some means
of shifting, nudging those incentives that
drive our behavior-- through funders, through
journals, through institutions-- so that researchers
have a reason to embrace moving toward more
open practices.
So I'd like to do for the rest of the time
that we have is to summarize some of our activities
of these.
And then we'll be delighted to have some questions
and discussion about what other barriers or
what opportunities there are to try to align
scientific values and practices more closely.
Let me start with the big picture view of
how do we shift incentives, given the cultural
challenges that we face in science.
And we can characterize this in very simple
terms.
Sort of a psychology 101 perspective on scientific
behavior.
And that is to think about what are the means
with which researchers get the rewards that
they get.
And those being the primary drivers of behavior.
So right now, my primary means of getting
the key reward-- publication-- are focused
on the outcomes of the
research.
The things that we do in the lab, the more
likely we are to have novel, positive, clean
results, the more likely I am to get that
reward that I need-- publication and publication
in prestigious outlets.
So if this is the singular model of incentive,
of reward, then everything hinges on outcomes.
On producing amazing, sexy, exciting results,
and everything else is essentially irrelevant
to how it is I advance in my career.
So how do we change that model so that it
isn't just a singular reward system?
Well one obvious thing to do is add additional
means.
So instead of me just being rewarded on the
outcomes that I produce, can we also nudge
those incentives so that sometimes, in part,
I'm awarded on the process by which I pursue
those outcomes.
Right?
The quality of my methodology, the accessibility,
the transparency of that methodology.
Evidence for reproducibility of the process
by which I generate my findings.
If those can also be a mechanism of reward,
then it isn't just the outcomes.
Although we will never get rid of outcomes
because people who discover more amazing things
will be rewarded more than people who don't.
But we can add additional means of getting
rewards so that the process also is part of
career advancement.
Likewise, we can diversify the rewards.
So it isn't just getting publication and having
the journal article be the sole mechanism
of advancement.
But also, the generation of important research
content, right?
So a person who generates an amazingly important
data set should be rewarded for that as a
scholarly unit of its own.
The data being a mechanism of scholarly advancement.
The materials, the analytic scripts and code
that are generated are themselves scholarly
contributions and could be credited as such,
rather than having it solely be through the
getting your name on a paper, and particularly--
getting your name first or last on that paper.
So most of our strategies are thinking about
ways to diversify means and rewards across
the existing incentive structures that drive
researchers' behaviors today.
So let me start with an example that's a trivially
easy or simple one.
And that is to signal desirable behaviors.
So this is an example of badges to reward
open practices.
So we developed these badges and there's a
committee of researchers from a variety of
different fields that help maintain the specifications
for what it means to have open data, or open
materials, or have preregistered your research
design.
Define in advance what you're doing and how
you're going to do it.
A journal can adopt these badges.
And then when my paper gets accepted, can
invite me to say, would you like any of these
badges to be attached to your paper?
So it appears there.
And if you can meet the specifications, then
you get the badge.
And then there would be a link, for example,
with open data to-- how someone can access
your data in an independent repository.
No badges are silly.
They are a trivial thing.
But in this case, they are signals of something
that's valued in the research community.
Openness and valued, but no one knows when
someone else is being open in their
practices, right?
There aren't any signals for doing those extra
things to be more open or transparent in one's
work.
And so providing a signal of evidence that
someone is doing a desirable behavior-- especially
when it's not easy to see otherwise-- could
be a powerful shift.
Very simple, but powerful shift in the incentives
that drive individual researcher's behaviors.
They may be more willing to do those extra
steps just to be able to signal that they
care about these issues, that they are pursuing
open practices.
So we worked with the journal Psychological
Science to-- as the first journal that adopted
badges.
And they adopted on January 1st, 2014.
And what I'm showing you here is an investigation
of the effect of badges-- this new policy
of offering badges at Psychological Science,
compared to four comparison journals in psychology.
And the y-axis is showing the percent of articles
for every half year, from 2012 to the end
of 2013, for the percent of articles that
said the data were available in an independent
repository.
And Psychological Science, in black, shows
about 3% of their articles, on average, each
half year were-- had data available in a repository.
And the other journals, likewise, had low
amounts.
So then, Psychological Science adopts badges
January 1st, 2014, and then this is what happens.
So by the first half of 2015, 39% of the articles
in Psychological Science had open data in
a repository.
And the only change was the introduction of
this policy-- of the opportunity to apply
for a badge on the article.
It has no implication, other than signaling
to the others in your research community,
that you did this particular practice.
So it is a trivial change, but it had an inordinately
strong impact on behavior-- 13-fold increase
the rates of data sharing-- at least in this
example.
So that-- it isn't magical abilities in any
particular way.
It's just leveraging the fact that the values
already exist.
As I showed you on that first slide of Anderson
and her colleagues, people already endorse
the norm of openness.
They're just not rewarded for behaving that
way.
So by providing a simple signal, that can
dramatically increase people's likelihood
of adhering to the values that they already
have.
And in doing so in effective ways.
OK so that's one example.
To introduce the next example, I want to just
give a research example of this challenge
of selective reporting and how it can make
the published literature look more credible
than it is.
And there's lots of good research examples
in clinical trials and other fields with this.
This example comes from the social sciences.
And what I'm showing you here is a comparison
of studies that were preregistered and what
the methodology was going to be done, versus
what was actually reported in the paper that
came out in the end.
So Annie Franco and her colleagues took advantage
of a NSF-funded project called TESS- this
is Time Series Experiments in Social Sciences.
And what TESS is it's a coordinated effort
to give researchers in the disciplines access
to a representative sample of adults to do
experiments.
Those are very precious samples.
They're hard to get and recruit and maintain.
And so this is a valued resource.
So what researchers in the field can do is
they can design their protocol and then they
submit it to TESS for peer review.
And if TESS accepts it, then TESS runs that
protocol on this sample of-- representative
sample of adults, and then sends you the data.
The condition for the researchers getting
access to this as a free resource is that
you have to make your protocol public and
the data public so that others can review
it.
And so what it creates is this opportunity
to see what was actually in the research.
Because we almost never-- in basic and preclinical
sciences-- almost never know what the precise
methodology was, just what was in the report.
Versus what ends up in the report-- what do
they say they did in their project?
And so what I'm showing you on the left here--
on the x-axis is the number of experimental
conditions or treatment arms that were actually
in the study, from zero to five in the questionnaire--
in the data as it was collected.
And the y-axis is the number of experimental
conditions or treatment arms that were reported
in the paper.
Where they said that these conditions did
occur.
And what you can see is that if every paper
reported all of the conditions that were in
the experiment, then all of the dots would
be on the diagonal line.
The 40% of the studies in this case left out
one or more of the experimental conditions--
just didn't mention that they had occurred
in the paper, even though they had occurred
in the protocol.
On the panel on the right is the same thing,
but now with the outcome variables.
So on the x-axis is showing the number of
outcome variables that were actually in the
experiment as it was conducted.
And on the y-axis is the number of outcome
variables that were reported in the paper,
at the end in the published article.
70% of the articles left out one or more of
the outcome variables that was actually in
the study.
Now it's possible that that happens-- that
happens for a lot of different reasons.
And it may not be consequential if there's
no particular bias in what's likely to be
reported in the paper versus what's likely
to be left out.
But because this is open data, Franco and
her colleagues were able to follow up and
look at what was included and what was excluded
from the paper.
And what they found was that for the 122 reported
tests that were included in the paper, the
median p value was 0.02, so they were positive
results, right?
P less than 0.05 is the standard metric for
deciding whether you obtain a positive result.
The median effect size was 0.29, so almost
a third of a standard deviation, approximately.
And 63% of the results that were reported
were positive results.
So then they went-- because they have the
access to the raw data-- to the result the
outcome variables that were reported.
And what they observed is that there were
147 of those.
The median p value was 0.35.
The median effect size was 0.13, less than
half.
And only 23% of those were significant effects.
So this suggests that there is a substantial
bias in what outcomes are likely to get reported
in the paper.
Positive
outcomes, compared to the outcomes that were
actually observed, suggesting that the reported
research-- that the papers at the end were
more beautiful, more clean, better stories
than the data actually suggested.
So that's a significant challenge and it's
only identifiable because we can tell the
difference between what was planned at the
outset and what was done and reported at the
end.
And this is related to a very important distinction
in the philosophy of science, which is two
different modes of research, right?
In one mode, we are in the context of justification.
We have a hypothesis that we want to acquire
data to test.
And so this is-- in hypothesis-testing mode,
we are in confirmatory approach to analysis,
right?
We are laying out a hypothesis, a methodology,
a way we're going to analyze the data that
we obtain from that methodology.
And then we go out and get data and then confront
our hypothesis with the data.
So the decisions, in this case, about the
hypothesis and the analysis plan, are independent
of the data itself.
You don't get to know what the data are because
you have to make your commitments to what
your hypothesis is and how you would analyze
it in advance in order to confront that hypothesis.
The other mode of analysis is when we're in
the context of discovery.
Where we're using data in order to generate
hypotheses.
We're getting in the weeds and looking at
data where we don't have a clear sense of
a hypothesis or a overall theory.
And we're exploring that in order to see where
things might occur.
So that once we can generate those hypotheses--
once we have ideas-- we can then later confront
them, do a different study in order to test
those hypotheses.
Those decisions, in the context of exploration,
are data-contingent.
We're using data to inform how we are analyzing
the data.
The importance of this distinction is-- it's
important for a number of reasons.
But there is a practice that is central to
making clear when we're in one mode of analysis
or the other.
And both of these modes are critical for scientific
advancement.
And the key thing that preregistration does
is clarify when we are in the context of discovery
versus the context of justification.
Because mixing these two up has important
implications.
So why is this distinction important?
Well, the typical tools of statistical inference--
using p-values, for example, in null hypothesis
significance testing, are interpretable only
in the context of confirmation.
Where you know precisely the number and kind
of inference tests you are going to do, and
then can apply corrective processes for the
number of tests versus the likelihood of them
being false positives.
But when we're in the context of discovery--
when we're making choices contingent on the
data-- p-values lose their diagnosticity.
They don't have the informative [INAUDIBLE]
that they have, because there are many possible
analyses we could have done that we either
did do and ignored or didn't do because we
didn't think to do them, given what we saw
in the data itself.
Andrew Gelman, for example, calls this the
garden of forking paths.
When you're confronted with many possibilities
as you observe the data, many of those paths
wither away very easily and quickly and you
never pursue them.
If you hadn't known the data, you might have
pursued those tests.
And so the-- that causes-- the fact that the
p-values are not interpretable in that context--
they're non-diagnostic increases the likelihood
of false discoveries when you're in exploratory
mode when you are using p-values to draw differences.
So the key challenge for not distinguishing,
via preregistration, when you're in a context
of justification versus discovery is that
presenting exploratory results as confirmatory
can increase the publishability, right?
I see more positive results.
I get more interested in those.
I start to draw interpretations and theories
that explain those.
But at the cost of the credibility-- of the
likelihood that they are false positives and
not aligned with reality.
So in the ideal model of how research operates,
because we're doing all of these simultaneously,
is one where we would generate a study-- where
we do studies for some reason.
And we write down, why is it that we are doing
this study?
What is the purpose of this study?
What are we trying to find or infer?
And many times we get into a new domain with
very little idea of where it might go.
We have some ideas, so it may be a very simple--
we're going to try this one thing to start.
But really this is an exploratory investigation.
So we write down what that is.
We commit to that in advance is our very constrained
view of what we're testing as a hypothesis.
And this is now routine in my lab.
We pre-register everything.
Once we've analyzed the data in that very
simple way that we started, then we take that
data set and we explore the heck out of it.
We move into exploratory mode of analysis
where we are trying to now unpack this phenomenon.
Where we had some interesting questions, but
we had very little idea of what direction
to go.
And that exploratory mode of analysis gives
us now some ideas, some hypotheses, that we
can start to shape the phenomenon that we're
investigating.
That then inspires the next study.
And in that study, we can preregister our
design.
Now that we have some hypotheses pre-registered,
what we're going to do to test that and how
we're going to analyze it.
And then move right back into exploratory
mode once we discover how wrong we were that
time, too.
And then back and forth and back and forth.
So this concept of pre-registration is well
known now with clinical sciences because it's
required for certain types of clinical trials.
But it is relatively unknown and certainly
not practiced in most basic and pre-clinical
areas of research.
And even though the value may be seen as clear,
there is lack of familiarity because it often
was disruptive to the workflows that we have
for how it is we do our research.
Whether it's experimental data questions,
whether it's working with existing data sets,
or otherwise, there are lots of different
ways in which we can create better distinctions
between our confirmatory and exploratory modes
of analysis.
So one initiative that we have to try to promote
awareness and education about the value of
preregistration is called the preregistration
challenge.
And you can visit it at the link here.
The idea of the pre-registration challenge
is that we are giving 1,000 $1,000 awards
to the first 1,000 researchers that publish
the results of a preregistered study, in an
eligible journal.
Really, the goal for this is an awareness
and education campaign.
So when you go to the website, you get lots
of information about what preregistration
is, how it works, some background reading
materials, process information.
And then there is a guided workflow that helps
researchers sort of take the steps for how
they can pre-register their study and actually
walk them through preregistration of a research
design.
And then a very rapid review process to confirm
that all of the things that were-- were preregistered.
And then the person goes ahead and does their
research.
So our suspicion, our expectation, is that
once researchers try preregistration for their
area of work-- because it's a high barrier
to initiate, because it is a disruption to
the ordinary workflow.
But once they try it, it is relatively likely
become a habit.
Because very quickly, one can experience the
benefits of preregistration.
I've mentioned before that my lab does preregistration
for all the research we do now.
And the benefits are very high.
Because we do a lot more upfront planning
and identification of problems before we actually
initiate data collection.
So we end up being more efficient, not less,
because of that planning process.
We've had a number of times where we thought
we had a design that was going to be effective
for testing the hypothesis that we were looking
to investigate in the first place and then
discovered we had some flaw in the design
that wouldn't have allowed us to test it the
way that we wanted.
So having done that in advance and actually
writing it down, writing down our analysis
plan, confronts us with that without the waste
of the data collection.
And likewise, for those areas of research
where there's a lot of variations, the paradigmatic
approach in the methodology-- pre-registration
is very efficient.
Because we preregister-- we develop the protocol
for one study and then we just adapt it incrementally
with the experiments as they go through the
sequence of research that we do.
So that's something that's worth trying out
if you have any interest at all.
There is another related initiative that really
tries to get into the incentives that researchers
have driving them now in that publication
process.
And that's-- this one is called registered
reports.
And you can go to the link there to find out
more information.
So the conts-- the contents of registered
reports-- this is the cartoon version of how
we do research, right?
Design a study, collect and analyze the data,
write up a report, and publish it.
But of course, it's not that simple.
There is that barrier of peer review, that's
in my way from once I finish that report to
actually publishing it.
Now in this standard model, the-- all of the
incentives for me to get publication that
I need are making that report
as likely as possible to make it through peer
review.
So I need it to be a novel story, it needs
to be clean and nice, any positive results.
Everything that peer reviewers will not hate,
I have to do and try to get that report looking
as good as possible.
Likewise, for peer reviewers, their incentives
are tied into their commitments to the findings
that I'm reporting.
If I'm in a contentious area of research,
and I get peer reviewers that like what I
found, they may also like the methodology.
That reinforces their worldview.
Whereas, if they don't like what I found--
if it challenges a particular finding that
they've had, or a particular perspective,
then they may be much more likely to identify
all kinds of problems in the methodology,
reinforcing their negative view of the results
itself.
So what register reports does is shift these
incentives by making one simple change to
the review process.
And that is moving peer review at the journal
to right after the design phase.
So what I do as an author, when I submit a
registered report to a journal, is I submit
the research question, the method-- the background
for why that's an important question, and
the methodology that I'm going to use to test
that question.
And I might have some preliminary experiments,
for example, showing the viability of the
approach or something.
But the results are not known because those
experiments have not been done.
And the peer reviewers evaluate the quality
of the question, the importance of the question,
and the quality of a methodology to [? tackle
?] question.
Do we need to know the answer to this, and
is this methodology effective, sufficient,
formed to be a good way to evaluate the outcomes
of this research?
And then it--that passes peer review, the
journal gives an in principle acceptance to
the paper.
They say, we not publish this, regardless
of whether it's a positive or negative result.
As long as you did the methodology [INAUDIBLE]
with the methodology of the paper.
You didn't just, you know, [INAUDIBLE] and
actually get the data, right?
[INAUDIBLE]
So the key here is that it shifts incentives
for everybody in the process.
Just enough.
So it's still about getting a publication.
That's how the world works that we're in now.
But the incentives for me as an author are
focused me asking the most important questions
that I can and developing the most robust
methodology that I can to test them.
The incentives for peer reviewers are now,
how can I evaluate this methodology?
But also my feedback.
Instead of saying what we did wrong and you
should have done-- in experiments already
finished.
Now my feedback is, how can I improve your
experiment?
And so as an author I can feel more grateful
to reviewers for identifying problems at this
stage because I have an opportunity to actually
fix them in the methodology before the experiments
are done.
So it makes the process much more collaborative.
The-- so so far, we have 50 journals, I think,
that have adopted this as a publishing option,
in addition to the traditional process of
research.
And both-- it can't be a comprehensive replacement
because there's a lot of things that are real
discoveries that aren't things that are anticipated
in advance.
You don't have to study to do, but you get
a left turn, all of a sudden, in doing research.
And a lot of those will appear in the normal
publication process as it occurs now.
Or would be things that happened in the introduction
for one of these kinds of papers.
And then you do a follow-up experiment to
really nail that phenomenon that came out
of the blue during that line of research.
OK.
So those examples-- I give you badges, and
preregistration challenge, and registered
reports-- are some efforts to try to nudge
a variety of the different incentives so that
researchers are rewarded for being more open
in their practice and trying to pursue practices
that are likely to increase the reproducibility
of the work.
And trying to fit those into the existing
reinforcements and reward systems that researchers
are living by.
The other half, or most of what we spend our
time on is the technology development to support
researchers to be more open in their research.
And so I want to spend the rest of the time
that I have to give you an overview of what
we're trying to do with the technology to
sort of support the shift towards more open
practices.
And really that, at the core of this, is not--
is a very simple idea for how we can improve
research.
And that is one that was instructed to us
in kindergarten for how we should behave.
And that is to show our work and to share.
There there's very little else that we really
need to do at a system level, I think, to
improve research practices.
One of the great things about science is that
it's an open marketplace of ideas.
People are seeing ideas, being skeptical of
others' ideas, challenging them, extending
them, re-using them, transforming them.
And over time, some stuff pops out of that
brew of marketplace as surviving-- as getting
through that skeptical process and having
some value beyond just the exploration of
the idea itself.
For that process to work efficiently, main
thing that we need to know is what are the
basis of people's claims?
How are they arriving at those claims so that
I can actually critique them?
So that that process can self-correct?
Because without access to the background information,
we don't know how to self-correct.
We don't know how to critique the findings
as effectively as we can.
And so if nothing else, if we can make that
process more accessible and more transparent,
more open, than self-correction will work
as we imagine it all could.
So that openness for-- from our perspective,
applies to three different areas of practice.
Open access is very familiar, right?
Papers-- making papers more accessible to
more people, rather than being behind, for
example, subscription services.
Open data is a very prominent and ongoing
discussion now.
Is how do we make the content of our research--
the data, the materials, the protocols, the
code-- more accessible to others?
But a critical third piece, that isn't yet
as much of a discussion, is open workflow.
The process by which I generate those data
and process by which I analyze this data and
draw inference.
Can we make that more accessible for others?
Because that process, like preregistration,
is just as important as the data itself to
understand the basis of claims that come out
of it.
So all three of those are part of the various
approaches to building technology infrastructure
tools to help researchers do their research.
And all of this is organized through the Open
Science Framework, and that's at osf.io.
All of the tools we build are free and open
source-- we build exclusively public goods.
And the Open Science Framework is a scholarly
commons that has as its first mission to help
researchers manage their own research for
their own use-- privately.
So when you go to the OSF, you can sign up
for an account.
When you have an account, you can easily create
projects, you add materials and data-- things
that you're working on those projects to those.
Those are all then stored in cloud-based archival
services.
You can add collaborators to those projects,
so that they have access to those work spaces
as well.
And all of that can be done privately.
So with the OSF, you never have to make anything
public you don't want to.
And the problem that we're trying to solve
with this infrastructure, by allowing this
privacy, is researchers maintaining their
old data and materials for their own use,
right?
The person that loses the most information
from my research is me.
Because we have lots of different projects
in the lab.
We have lots of people coming in and out of
the lab-- postdocs and graduate students and
research assistants.
And when one person leaves or one computer
dies, a lot of information leaves with them.
So what the OSF solves is that archival problem.
Is a cloud-based solution, where every project
is stored for the lab in that space.
And it also is a collective knowledge base.
So that post-doc leaves, I don't lose because
of that person's ad hoc organization system.
I don't lose the information, the data, the
source materials, the notebook, the electronic
note book, et cetera.
I don't need that information because that
person is gone, too.
So the key, though, is we solve that problem--
trying to make this online resource a repository
for one's lab's own use.
While then simultaneously making it trivial--
make parts or all of that more accessible
others.
Make it open.
So on every project, and every component of
every project, there's a little button that
says make public.
And If I click that button, it says are you
sure you want to make that public?
And if I say yes, then that part of the project
is public.
And so by that, we have integrated private
and public workflows.
So that my lab can be doing its research.
And we may have a longitudinal project that
we're going to do for many years.
And we're not ready to make the data set available,
but we are ready to sort of make some of the
materials-- other people could use these materials
or they might have ideas or collaborations
if they see some of
the methodology that we're pursuing.
So we make that part of the project public
while we continue to work with the other parts
privately in the OSF with just the collaborators.
So the idea is to reduce the barriers to openness--
to be trivial barriers, right?
Not add on to people's workflow and make it
append to their work-- busy work days.
But rather, provide a tool that has value
for maintaining your own research for your
own use and make it easy to integrate that
private workflow management with making things
publicly accessible.
At the core of the OSF is an API to connect
services around the entire research lifecycle.
And so, once a particular service is connected
to the OSF, and that service is connected
to all of the other services that are already
connected to the OSF.
So these are services that are connected as
of today-- Zotero and Mendeley, citation management
services.
Data storage, like Google Drive, box.com,
Dropbox, Amazon Web-- Amazon S3.
GitHub for code, JASP stats for data analysis,
and then other archival environments like
ThinkShare or Dataverse.
And then we also have a number of other ones
that are in development now through grants
that we provided to variety of different groups
to connect their service.
The idea for this is-- one, that we can help
researchers get around their research lifecycle
more efficiently, with less loss of information,
by connecting all the services they use together.
And by connecting those services, make researchers
more efficient getting around the lifecycle,
but also decrease the likelihood of error--
of information going in and out of the different
services that you use.
The analytics platform, where it's stored,
with how they visualize their data, with writing
up for publication, et cetera.
So if we can minimize error and increase efficiency
getting around the lifecycle, then researchers
win.
They get more efficient in doing their work.
And by connecting all these services together,
larger collaborative teams can use the same
set of services, even if only a subset of
them actually make use of them, right?
So I might use GitHub because I'm familiar
with command line and code.
But one of my collaborators might not use
GitHub.
But by representing in the OSF and the simplified
interface, I can still give those collaborators
access to the code and scripts that we're
using without them having to be a regular
user of the service.
And then a byproduct of all of that is that
the entire process, the entire research lifecycle,
is more reproducible.
Because as we've connected these together,
we can log what happens-- actually follow
the process of doing the research in order
to make the entire thing more reproducible
overall.
So another example-- so this is an open API--
public API-- so anybody can connect their
services.
And the goal is to make it so that any kind
of service that supports research can be connected
to the life cycle.
So for example, the research computing center
at Notre Dame has a computational services
engine that they use
to support their researchers.
They collected that to the OSF.
And by connecting it to the OSF-- then instead
of having to negotiate developing API relationships
with each individual repository, once it was
connected to the OSF then Notre Dame users
of that computational platform could apply
data that's stored in any environment that's
already connected to the OSF.
Whether it's on Dropbox, or Amazon S3 or their
own cloud service, or box.com, or otherwise.
So the benefits can be moved rapidly to scale
by connecting particular services that support
one's own area of research.
The other key part of the OSF is that it is
a layered system.
So that those core services at the base here--
the ecosystem of connecting services together,
the data upon which it's all collected, and
then the services-authentication, security,
management workflow, rendering in the browser.
All those things are modularized in components
so that they can be put together in a variety
of different ways with different interfaces
applied to them.
So the OSF is one interface to access all
of those different services and all of that
data and workflow management.
But you can build any interface on top of
that core set of services because it's completely
modularized from how the information is visualized.
So one of those-- one example of that, just
to illustrate, is a generalized pre-print
service that we have developed- and I'll show
you some images up in a second.
And that's at the second layer.
And then that service is modularized so that
it can be branded for any community to run
their own version of that service.
And so with the pre-print service, we have
10 or 11 now-- different groups that either
have either launched or are soon to launch
their own pre-print service all built on the
OSF.
And done so very efficiently.
And by this layering, we can enable scholarly
communities to focus on the areas of expertise
that they have.
So, for example, SOCARXIV, an open archive
for the social scientists, is run by sociologists.
And they care very much about the content
of the research in the pre-prints and their
research community that is using pre-prints.
But they aren't experts and don't really care
about how security is managed in the service,
[INAUDIBLE] and the kinds of databases are
used.
That's left to the technical experts to care
about and focus their energies on.
And then scholarly communication experts,
who think about information transmission and
how pre-print services can get designed, focus
their efforts on designing that interface
layer between them.
And then the content area experts focus on
just delivery of the service and engaging
their scholarly community.
And so this really provides a great deal of
flexibility for the research community to
be able to employ the same set of scholarly
tools-- scholarly commons-- for a lot of different
uses.
It can open up more of the research lifecycle.
So pre-prints are a way to make research more
accessible to more people more quickly.
And so if you go to OSF.io/preprints, you
can find the general search infrastructure.
And this is an aggregated search across a
variety of different pre-print services, whether
they're hosted by the Center for Open Science
or not.
And you can search
against all of those in a single interface.
And then simultaneously, each of those individual
services has their own URL and place for them
to manage their own service, so that they
can run pre-prints on their own.
So if anybody's interested in starting a pre-print
service, please do contact.
We're happy to engage you on launching a pre-print
service for your community.
And I'm going to close so that there's a couple
minutes for questions.
But just to give an illustration of OSF institutions,
here's another view of that same set of core
tools.
I mentioned that Notre Dame Center for Research
Computing computational service connection
as an example.
But institutions can sign up for it OSF as
an institutional service-- it's a free service
for institutions, too.
And then make it easy for their researchers
to get onto the service-- single sign on capacity,
so people can use their university credentials.
And they can connect whatever services that
they have in their research environment, like
a institutional repository, to the OSF to
make access of those services more efficient
within their research community.
There are a variety of different institutions
that are already using OSF institutions.
This is just to illustrate.
So let me close with that because there may
be some questions and there's a few minutes
left.
But just to point you to some links where
if you'd like to follow up with information
to use any of these services.
I didn't talk about training, but we have
free trainings that can be done remotely or
in person on open or reproducible practices.
And we are a service organization.
So if you have a service that you use and
you want to connect to the OSF.
If you have a community that you like to have--
make use of the OSF or get involved in the
pre-reg challenge.
Or if you're a journal editor-- you want to
pursue pre-registered reports as a pilot for
your journal.
Just feel free to get in touch with us for
any of these things.
And here are links.
And if you Google my name, I come up.
There aren't many Nosek's in the world.
So happy to chat.
So thanks very much for your time and attention.
I really appreciate it.
Brian, thanks so much for this great talk.
We do have, actually-- you got a lot of questions.
I'm going to try and synthesize a few of them
together and maybe we can get through one
or two of them.
Obviously the badge system that you've proposed
here and described caught a lot of interest.
And I think there's one or two questions around--
well actually, several questions around that.
But maybe one or two T ones.
One-- is it possible to apply the badges retrospectively
or retroactively to work that's already published
and how far back could we go, if that was
possible?
And secondly, how would abstract services
or indexing services-- like the National Library
of Medicine's PubMed or Medline-- support
badges, do you think?
Would it be possible, for instance, to add
something like that to their search mechanisms
or their-- as a filter?
So let's start with those two questions first.
Yeah.
Yeah, great question.
And the answer is yes-- possible for both.
And not active for both.
So anybody can be
a badge issuer.
And one of the things that we-- is in development,
it isn't in production yet, is a badge bakery.
So that the badge itself has embedded in it
the metadata about who was the issuer, what
was it issued for.
You know, there is a DOI-- inserting the DOI,
et cetera.
And that is to provide as much flexibility
as possible for these different kinds of uses--
retrospective, prospective, different groups
applying badges.
And then make them machine readable and recoverable
across a variety of different issuers.
So yes, that's possible.
And also, for the latter point, I'm getting
badges integrated with within NLM or other
services.
We're very interested in pursuing those kinds
of solutions.
Because the real power of things like badges
are when they move to scale, right?
It's great to show an example in a single
journal.
What really the practice as a normative practice-and
especially getting integrated with things
like one CB and other mechanisms of reward,
right?
You can submit to your institution what portion
of your data is openly accessible for others
as a mechanism of indicating good process.
That will only work when it moves to scale.
And so we're very interested in pursuing collaborations--
like with NLM and other groups for that.
Great.
So maybe one last question before we go.
And this is more of a-- sort of a personal
question as a couple of people have asked
this.
But as a leader in this field, what was the
moment that sort of got you into open science?
What was the light bulb or the point in time
which you sort of thought and saw that this
was this was a key issue?
Yeah I suspect that my experience was like
a lot of people's, where I didn't realize
that science wasn't open when I started in
it.
So it was only when I got into grad school
and I took a methodology class with Alan [? Casden
?] my first year.
Where I realized-- you know, we read all of
these papers in the 60s and 70s-- all these
challenges of how science is done and what
the reality is.
And I'm sort of stunned by that, right?
I thought it was sort of like how we talked
about in second grade.
You know, I'm curious about a question.
And I study it and then I write down what
I did and I share that with the people.
And then they say, oh what about this?
What about that?
And the fact that it doesn't operate like
that was sort of an awakening.
My lab in grad school and in my lab-- since
I've been a faculty member-- I've always had
a technical part of the lab.
We've always just built tools to try to make
our research more efficient and more useful
and more accessible.
So I just sort of said, well we can make our
own data more available, even if we can't--
even if the field isn't operating that way.
So we've always had that voice-- and applying
for grants to try to increase-- build tools
to make things more accessible.
But the actual-- the development of the Center
for Open Science, which is a spin out from
my lab, really was sort of a-- not a plan,
but sort of a grasping at an opportunity that
sort of appeared.
So I didn't talk about our reproducibility
projects.
But we've done some large-scale replication
projects of studies-- in psychology first--
my field.
And we have one ongoing now in cancer biology.
And we started to do that replication project
just as a lab
project-- the one for psychology-- at the
same time that we were building sort of an
initial version of the open science framework.
And that got a lot of press attention.
And then funders started calling.
And our primary funder-- the Laura and John
Arnolds foundation-- gave us a $5.25 million
award in order to start the center.
And so what was sort of aspirations that were
realistic, of wouldn't it be great if we could
build some tools that help a few people?
Turned into, oh my gosh, we could really start
an organization and maybe really push on this.
Let's go for it!
And so that was-- you know, that gift just
really changed the direction of how we did
this.
OK.
Well, we're at time.
So it's 10 o'clock on the west coast.
So again, Brian, thank you for your wonderful
insights on this.
It was-- it was inspirational to hear a lot
of this work.
And we'll end the session here.
Thanks very much.
I appreciate everybody attending.